let's have it let's have a go at this
one and but for all of these what I'm
trying to do is trying to help you see
that the actual answer that we get at
the end like why is the biggest number
and it's not that important to me what
I'm trying to get across to you is some
of the overall strategies you can use
for all of these that whatever problem
you've got it is an inequality and these
will be relevant okay
so the big overall idea that I want to
get across to you here is when you're
trying to get to somewhere that you
don't know a key part of mathematical
deductive logic is you start with
something you do know hopefully if it's
related to what you're trying to get to
you can apply some logic to get from
what you do know to what you don't
okay so the biggest problem with this is
the numbers are enormous right like in
fact in some look at a calculator on
them it's not actually someone try where
is this until you did your calculator
give you a number back what did it say
math error this is too big
did you get like weird scientific
notation is that what you got yeah okay
if you're like piranha know how to read
this okay or equally I could have put
and put more zeroes on the end here and
I could have just rendered this you know
impossible for your calculator to deal
with okay so what makes this problem
hard to access is its size therefore
classic mathematical strategy we saw
this right back from week one I'm just
going to compare it to a smaller problem
that I can deal with so what about these
guys these guys are clearly related to
the top ones right very very closely
related in fact but these I can deal
with what's 2 cubed is 8 and 3 squared
is 9 so I can say this I have an
inequality statement and I know it to be
true so what I want to try and do is use
this as my launchpad to get to something
that I don't know about ok now here's a
weird idea just write this off on the
side somewhere ok when we wrote down
something I think this is the example I
gave you right because this is an
equation it's an equation everything you
do to one side you have to do to the
other because otherwise it's not
balanced anymore right so for example
you can add to both sides you can say
I'll add 1 to both sides and that's ok
right however we also wrote down this I
think and while you can play by the same
rules and say for example add one to
both sides like this and it's still true
you can do some read things of
inequalities because you don't have to
keep everything balanced right all this
means is for example you could say five
is like five heavier than three five is
heavier than three it's got more mass to
it okay
so therefore so long as I add heavier
things on this side then I do on this
side it's still true isn't it for
example I can add something to the
left-hand side that's just don't make it
original and then add nothing to the
right-hand side and it's still true
isn't it
like if I add something to the left-hand
side and add nothing to the right-hand
side this is all good isn't it
by the same logic I can add something
really heavy to the left-hand side like
that and add something tiny to the
right-hand side and it's all still true
do you agree the same logic applies to
multiplication for exactly the same
reasons okay so therefore when you have
a look at this line here what I'm going
to do and you can't do this is equations
probably not dealing with equations I'm
going to multiply the left and the right
hand sides by different things that just
respect the inequality okay so you see
here it's like oh this is the big side
is the small side so put big things over
here put small things over here and
everything's all hunky-dory okay here I
can put small things here big things
here so in this case I'm going to
multiply this left hand side by itself
and then on the right hand side I'm
going to multiply that by itself as well
okay now why is this okay think about
this the reason it's okay is because
this is the small side this is the big
side so if I multiply this by a small
number and multiply this by a big number
it's all still fine and of course the
numbers are small enough at the moment
that we can verify that eight times
eight is
and nine times nine is so this is all
still good right so now let me write
this in a slightly more helpful format
two cubed squared is less than three
squared squared but now that you realize
that and you understand how I got from
this line to this line you can see I can
do this as many times as I like right
like I can keep on multiplying by two
cubed I could do it again
and I can keep multiplying by three
squared I can do it again and this is
still true in fact borrowing from our
idea of series and sequences if this is
not true that I can do this until the
cows come home as many times as you want
so long as and is a positive integer so
interesting new piece of notation for
you that guy there if the Greek letter
epsilon so that's why it's it's curved
like that and it means and is some
number that's an element of this set of
numbers so n is a positive integer so
this number here could be one or two or
three or four or for example have a look
at the original question what might be a
good end to choose 100
you see where I've gone you see how I've
taken think something I knew something
which is just a simple fact numerically
and then I applied some logic to it to
get to somewhere that I didn't know
before happy times
mix-ins okay